on passe maintenant à la troisième
partie de notre émission alors c'est
l'histoire d'un proche du président un
familier de l'elysée qui l'on ne voyait
partout et qui ne figurait sur aucun
organigramme un amateur de coup de poing
qui s'amusent à un jour à jouer les
auxiliaires de police sans autorisation
dans une manifestation sans se douter
qu'il allait déclencher un scandale au
sommet de l'état comment la faire
benalla a fait trembler la macro ni
c'est un sujet de jérôme un billet une
vidéo qui fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux puis une révélation fracassante
l'homme qui sur ces images violentes des
manifestants travail en fait à l'elysée
c'est alexandre benalla la sphère
s'emballe à l'assemblée les oppositions
profite de la tribune pour interpeller
le gouvernement sur ce sujet le grand
projet de réforme des institutions et
empêcher il prévoyait la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires et
l'introduction de la proportionnelle
mais face au pugilat la garde des sceaux
de l'époque capitule le gouvernement a
décidé de suspendre l'examen de la
révision constitutionnelle
exit les promesses phares de renouveler
profondément la vème république et les
parlementaires ne lâche pas le
gouvernement gérard collomb ministre de
l'intérieur est sommé de s'expliquer
devant le sénat
sans convaincre je lis les journaux
comme vous et il ya toute une partie de
l'histoire de monsieur benalla que
franchement je découvre de plus en plus
face à ce fiasco emmanuel macron en
personne ce mot il défend son
collaborateur et lors d'un moment de
convivialité avec les élus en marche
lâche cette phrase qui le place en
première ligne s'il vaut la responsable
il est devant vous
[Applaudissements]
le responsable c'est lui tout en se
sachant à l'abri d'une convocation des
parlementaires ou de la justice les
députés entrent en cette fin juillet
2018 de faire tomber le gouvernement
mais les motions de censure sont
repoussées l'été fait retomber la
pression mais les conséquences
politiques sont là
la révision constitutionnelle ne fera
jamais son retour l'enquète du sénat
durera de longs mois pendant encore un
peu plus les relations entre l'exécutif
et la chambre haute du parlement une
partie des promesses de campagne
d'emmanuel macron se sont envolés dans
cette affaire qui reste une des crises
majeures de son quinquennat alors le
procès d'alexandre benalla s'est ouvert
lundi au tribunal correctionnel de paris
il doit se tenir jusqu'à la fin du mois
il sera jugé pour des violences commises
lors des manifestations mais aussi pour
utilisation frauduleuse de passeports
diplomatiques mais on ne va pas se
pencher ce soir sur la chronique
judiciaire ou sur l'aspect faits divers
ce qui nous intéresse ici c'est de
comprendre ce que cette affaire raconte
du quinquennat avec moi pour en débattre
françois-xavier bourmaud vous êtes grand
reporter au figaro en charge le suivi de
l'elysée et coauteur d'un livre qui
vient de paraître macron le pen le tango
des fossoyeurs aux éditions de
l'archipel bonsoir france que vous avez
à vos côtés jean garrigues historien
auteur notamment de les scandales de la
république de panama à la sphère benalla
aux éditions du nouveau monde
j'accueille aussi paul cassia professeur
de droit public à paris rien vous avez
beaucoup écrit sur la sphère benalla des
tribunes sur mediapart dans le monde est
toujours à mes côtés notre chroniqueuse
laetitia krupa avant de commencer je
m'adresse à vous françois-xavier
bourmaud pour faire appel à vos
souvenirs vous couvrez l'elysée pour le
figaro est-ce que vous souvenez de ce
que vous avez pensé quand vous avez
découvert la ferme et dallas comme tout
le monde je pense qu'il ya eu un peu de
un peu de sidération parce que quand la
sphère sort s'est présenté comme
un conseiller du président de la
république retrouvé à faire le coup de
poing dans une dans une manifestation
présentée comme ça on a vraiment
l'impression tout de suite qu'il se
passait quelque chose de totalement
irréaliste et qui ont en tout cas en
tout cas hors norme ça veut dire vous
n'y croyez pas si on se demande qui
s'est au début car après il ya benalla
qui arrive le nom sort le nom sort assez
vite on identifie on se souvient que si
c'était quelqu'un qui s'occupait de la
sécurité des mines macron pendant le
pendant la campagne on est puis au bas
mot deux hiérarques socialistes voient
là et avant et avons encore au parti
socialiste et donc méreau on comprend
tout de suite avec les mots qui sont
employés que la sphère va provoquer une
déflagration d'accord donc vous sentez
ddt le jour où vous lisez l'article que
ça va devenir une très grosse affaire
politique paul cassia vous publier dès
le surlendemain une tribune dans le
monde donc pour vous c'est tout de suite
une affaire politique oui c'est m'a
semblé une affaire très importante parce
qu'elle a révélé en creux de la manière
dont fonctionne l elysée cette volonté
de dissimuler des faits de ne pas saisir
le parquet de couvrir en réalité les
agissements d'alexandre benalla
d'annoncer qu'une sanction moi ce qui
m'a choqué en tant que juriste c'est le
fait que l'elysée annonce que
l'intéressé alexander avait été
sanctionné sanctionné par une mise à
quinze jours à peine 20 lots ce qui m'a
tout de suite interpellé c'est la
disproportion en négatif entre les faits
qui étaient reprochés alexandre bonnet
là et la soi-disant sanction beaucoup
trop légère à vos yeux oui parce que 15
jours de mise à pied ont été ce sont des
congés payés lorsque l'intéressé peut
continuer à percevoir sa rémunération on
nous a dit par la suite qu'alexandrine
ana n'avaient pas été payés ce qui n'a
jamais été démontrée en tout état de
cause cette sanction est manifestement
insuffisante et d'ailleurs quelques
temps plus tard quelques jours après
alexandre ménard a été licencié pour des
faits qu'il avait commis le 1er mai j'en
ai juste une minute vers vous françois
xavier c'était pas où vous dites on
arrive à identifier alexandre bédat est
ce que vous savez ce qu'il fait à
l'elysée alors c'est qui s'occupe des
mails macron qui fait partie de l'équipe
rapprochée des manuels mâcon qui
travaillent avec lui mais sur les
détails précis de de son rôle c on sait
que c'est plutôt le l'homme qui lui
donne des coups de main quoi qui lui qui
lui facilite les choses un peu comme
pendant la campagne présidentielle c'est
quoi un homme de coups de main et assure
des shows non pendant là à un moment
pendant la campagne à un meeting ou
auquel emmanuel macron doit accéder mais
il ya une manifestation dehors et lui
trouve un chariot élévateur pour le
faire franchir un mur et accéder au
parking sans voir les manifestants par
exemple ces voix là c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui est malin qui des bruits
des coups qu'on a croisé assez souvent
effectivement autour de lui qui était
plutôt plutôt rigolo avec la la bande de
garde du corps de l'époque qui était
affecté à en marche jean garrigues même
question pour vous quand vous découvrez
cette affaire vous vous faites un livre
vous appelez ça un scandale de la
république c'est un scandale d'état
c'est une affaire d'état c'est quoi pour
vous la fermez là pour moi c'est pas une
affaire d'état parce que je considère
que ce n'est pas un système qui est qui
s'est révélée mais les excès d'un homme
en revanche moi je pense que ce cette
affaire elle révèle de 2,2 chose
paradoxale de notre système politique
d'une part l'amateurisme de ce qui s'est
passé au moment de la campagne d'ennahda
croquis direct leur a permis d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière de d'arriver au
pouvoir et des de la manière dont s'est
construit l'entourage de déminage macron
à l'elysée c'est à dire en ne
connaissant pas forcément les profils
des gens qui arrivaient et qui s'est
opéré autour de la candidature de les
entrepôts pouvoir à certains passer à
d'autres etc et de manière paradoxale en
même temps face et c'est le cas de le
dire pour les mamelles macron une un
vieux parfum d'anciens monde parce que
c'est ce qui était dit cette opacité
cette tentation tout de suite du repli
et delà de la non transparence c'est
quelque chose de très classique
ça m'a rappelé un petit peu le
fonctionnement de l'elysée au temps de
françois mitterrand notamment on était
vraiment dans ce dance est dans cette
opacité terrible et danser comment dire
dans ce flou organisationnel même
d'ailleurs benalla parle d'une 9e ni
organisationnel à propos de l'elysée
mais si vous voulez le paradoxe c'est
que vous avez quelque chose de très
nouveau qui est cet amateurisme 2 ma
chronique et quelque chose finalement
très traditionnelle qui est pas du tout
nouveau monde qui est ce vieux réflexe
voilà d'empêcher que la vérité ne puisse
voir le jour j'allais dire aussi tous
les présidents ne son tour t-il pas
d'homme de l'ombre plus ou moins
recommandables gens gagnent alors ça
c'est évidemment il ya toujours eu des
tirs d hommes de sac et de corde ce
serait un peu exagéré mais du temps de
pompidou vous aviez des deux conseillers
de l'ombre deux éminences risque était
pierre juillet et marie france garaud
dont on sait que sur un terrain plus
strictement politiques et des bas des
personnalités de cette corde comme nom
et mémé donc de mauvais coups aux boules
mais qui pouvait qu'ils pouvaient pour
dire de mauvais coups au tour de
françois mitterrand quelqu'un comme
françois de grossouvre dans la fonction
était quand même plus ou moins floues
dans l'organigramme et quelques autres
qui n'a pas bien fini d autres soucis
natoye bien fébrile et qui lui aussi
avait une arme à l'elysée il ya toujours
eu comme ça on pourrait évoquer le rôle
de michel poniatowski auprès de de
valéry giscard d'estaing ou
celui de jacques foccart
du temps du général de gaulle et de
georges pompidou ou d'autres
intermédiaires plus récents pourparlers
avec le moyen-orient où l'afrique
exactement on a beau jouer des
personnages le personnage de bella il
écrase tout fait tout à fait atypique et
c'est précisément parce qu'ils étaient
atypiques que je suppose il avait
intéressé emmanuel macron parce que
c'était un petit gars des banlieues qui
avait justement qu'il pouvait incarner
une sorte de méritocratie républicaine
et puis il ya un cas totalement pété les
plombs par rapport à l'exercice d'un
pouvoir qui lui est arrivé beaucoup trop
tôt je le suppose donc c'est un
personnage quand même atypique mais
cette tentation de ce super pouvoirs
qu'est la présidence de la république
parce qu'au fond c'est ça ce qu'on voit
dans cette affaire c'est la manière dont
benalla et le dit lui-même obtient de la
part de mystère l'inter la préfecture de
police des passe-droits des
autorisations un pouvoir
sport est ce qu'ils se réclament du
président de la république et ça pose un
vrai problème de d'institutions de deux
périmètres des pouvoirs donc ça pose des
problèmes qui relèvent de l'état ça
c'est sûr paul cassia emmanuel macron
avait promis une république exemplaire
est ce que c'est la sphère benalla qui
fracasse cette province elle sera cassée
à deux titres elle a fracassé sur le
plan pratique puisque comme ça vient
d'être dit loin de se montrer
exemplaires dans la gestion de la sphère
benalla vous contraint le président de
la république hier la gestion révélé un
visage qu'on attendait pas du tout d'un
jeune homme qui a écrit un ouvrage qui
s'appelle révolution et la sphère
benalla aussi fracassé sa trajectoire
présidentielle en ce sens que comme ça a
été dit dans votre reportage la première
conséquence est que la révision
constitutionnelle qui avait été proposé
quelques jours avant a été immédiatement
enterrées parce que il était absolument
impossible que le sénat donne son aval à
la modification qui était proposé compte
tenu compte tenu du contexte compte tenu
du contexte et des attaques proférées
par le président de la république à
l'encontre des institutions de la
république elle même donc le président a
braqué ont été le sénat une partie de la
presse et une partie des citoyens
sur la gestion de cette affaire
maintenant comme quand on s'interroge on
a vu dans les images tout à l'heure un
emmanuel macron qui qui viennent me
chercher en forêt quasiment du nicolas
sarkozy dans le texte est ce que
l'elysée a mesuré tout de suite
l'ampleur de la déflagration françois
xavier en fait quand emmanuel macron est
informé que alexandre reynal a fait le
coup de poing il est en australie c'est
c'est le 1er mai et donc il est informé
à distance donc il est dans d'autres
dans d'autres préoccupations en train de
négocier des accords avec les avec les
australiens puis quelques jours plus
tard il va partir en nouvelle calédonie
où le ballet à ouvéa donc ce que
l'information arrive en amont mais à
l'autre bout du monde avec du décalage
horaire il ya des manifestations en
france mais elle arrive dans un flux
dans un moment où
vraisemblablement pas ça ça préoccupe
juste pour nos téléspectateurs je
rappelle que tout le monde l'a prend en
fait le 18 juillet date de la parution
d'un article darien de chemin dans le
monde donc entre premiers mails 18
juillet voulait dire qu'ils n'ont pas
senti le danger potentiel de cette
affaire quand il est informé de
l'histoire il est il est ailleurs il
prend pas prof un rassembleur pas
forcément la mesure faut quand même pas
oublier que
emmanuel macron et sont ses proches son
commando qu'on menait la campagne
présidentielle c'est un groupe de
hussards qui sont partis à l'assaut de
l'elysée et contre tout en captant diniz
ont réussi leur coup alors qu'ils s'y
attendait pas qu'ils se sentaient vernis
et que dans ces cas là
forcément et il arrive en amateur dans
un cadre extrêmement contraint qui est
celui de l'elysée un peu en vainqueur
avec fa semblablement un peu d'arrogance
où on se croit tout permis pourquoi ne
se souvenir juste avant la révélation de
la faire avec son benalla conduit le bus
des bleus qui viennent de remporter le
exactement et qui descendent les champs
elysées à une vitesse phénoménale pour
arriver heures au palais de l'elysée au
grand dam de ses partisans qui s'étaient
réunis pour les voir ce sont les ce sont
les rois du monde et rien ne peut leur
résister donc il ya sans doute qu'ils
sous-estiment la portée de la faire
s'ils se font prendre
et vraisemblablement il ne pense pas se
faire prendre ccu sahara autour des
mêmes macron c'est des gens qui
verrouillaient la communication l'a vu
pendant la campagne il sortait pas
grand-chose de l'entourage de mâcon
parce que tout était extrêmement
verrouillé d'un point de vue de
communication l'éthicien comment vous
jugez que cette affaire a été gérée à
l'été 2010 8 quand elle sort ça illustre
tout ce qu'on vient d'entendre en fait
l'amateurisme l'erreur totale c'est en
fait c'est une escalade d'erreur déjà
vous avez raison et ils ne prennent pas
du tout en considération l'ampleur des
dégâts c'est une erreur d'appréciation
faut une monumentale or en com de crise
il faut savoir skis mais où on en est
tout de suite pour pour répliquer à eux
se disent non on va laisser passer l'été
ça va être étouffée mais vraiment c'est
cette idée là ils ne mesurent pas étant
des mesures par ladite sommet de l'état
la déflagration de l'ampleur des
dépréciations pas du tout et ensuite
alors après une fois que le monde sort
ce papier qui fait l'effet d'une bombe
quand même c'est vraiment de
l'amateurisme sur de l'amateurisme je
vous rappelle que ismaël et meulien qui
est le bras droit du chef de l'état à
l'époque balance via des comptes twitter
anonyme des vidéos une qui apparemment
n'a rien à voir puisque c'est des
manifestants qu'ils attaqueraient les
policiers mais le manifestant ce n'est
pas celui qui ensuite est frappé par
benalla est une autre c'est carrément
illégale puisque ça fait partie de la
vidéosurveillance on a causé aux pieds
nickelés sont déjà remis soit
barbouzeries si on est
impressionnant et ensuite ils se disent
tiens on va envoyer bruno roger petit
front téléspectateurs les petits c'est
donc un journaliste qui a été appelée
lisez prévention jeunesse voilà voilà
ali pour être porte parole de l'elysée
depuis il a été relégué à l'écriture des
discours mais mme moriau bref à l'époque
il est porte parole il n'a jamais rien
fait on n'en sait rien faire on le voit
plus ou moins hors hors micro et on
l'envoie on le balance conférence de
presse devant les journalistes pour à
déminer terrain écoutez il a largement
outrepassé cette autorisation est comme
une vidéo la montre et est intervenu
physiquement pour participer aux
opérations de maintien de l'ordre sa
hiérarchie n'a eu connaissance des faits
qu'a posteriori il a été immédiatement
convoqués par le directeur de cabinet du
président qui lui a notifié une sanction
disciplinaire
cette sanction vient punir un
comportement inacceptable et lui a été
notifié comme un dernier avertissement
avant licenciement cette sanction est la
plus grave jamais prononcée contre un
chargé de mission travaillant à l'elysée
alors nos souris sur le plateau c'est un
naufrage de communication pour total le
pauvre de situation ils le portent sur
lui en à malin avec lui c'est lui c'est
pas du tout il n'est pas convaincu et
c'est pour ça que manuel marque qu'on
reprend la main de façon aussi piloter
et orchestré c'est à dire que quand il
est devant les députés qu'il dise qu'il
vienne me chercher bien sûr qu'il sait
qu'une vidéo va chuter il faut être naïf
pour croire encore aujourd'hui qu'on a
réussi à piéger emmanuel macron il sait
très bien il le fait fuiter de cette
façon parce que c'est vrai que son
expression est un peu direct et qu'il
est compliqué de façon officielle
d'avoir cette expression là un peu à la
sarkozy qui viennent me chercher c'est
moi le responsable et à partir de là ça
devient une affaire macro mais c'était
une affaire macro depuis le début et
alors les premiers à se saisir de cette
affaire après les journalistes vont être
les sénateurs avec notamment la
commission denquête nous accueillons
alexandre tousart qui va nous expliquer
comment la chambre haute s'est saisie de
cette affaire
bonsoir à tous bonsoir lexandre alors la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale a
remis un rapport sur cette affaire
benalla un rapport publié en janvier
2019 et ce rapport il est très sévère
car il relève au final un grave
dysfonctionnement dans la sécurité du
président de la république puisque un
simple chargés de mission étaient armés
aux côtés du président alors que ce
n'était pas un policier ou un gendarme
et puis ensuite ce rapport dénonce le
manque de transparence dans le
fonctionnement de l'elysée on vous en
avait parlé un monsieur cassia notamment
dans le recrutement est dans le contrôle
des collaborateurs du président de la
république et puis enfin la commission
denquête fait part de ses soupçons sur
d'éventuels conflits d'intérêt avec une
puissance étrangère puisque souvenez
vous cette affaire avait révélé qu
alexandre benalla avait conclu des
contrats de sécurité privée avec un
oligarque russe alors ce rapport est
bien il fait grincer des dents dans
toute la macro ni et même jusqu'à
matignon car juste après sa publication
est bien le premier str edouard philippe
décidé d'improviser une déclaration est
là encore c'est un exercice de
communication est difficile il improvise
une déclaration sur le perron à matignon
souvenez vous
traditionnellement la séparation des
pouvoirs fait qu'il n'appartient pas ni
à l'assemblée nationale ni au sénat de
se prononcer sur l'organisation interne
de la présidence de la république en la
matière la commission d'enquêté du sénat
et le sénat ont choisi de se livrer à
une appréciation qui est je crois très
politique je n'en suis pas surpris mais
comme j'ai un attachement très vif et
très grand au principe de séparation des
pouvoirs j'en suis un peu déçu alors en
plus de ce rapport le sénat a décidé
également de transmettre à la justice
les dossiers de certaines personnes
auditionnées devant la commission
denquête alors notamment alexandre
benalla et son collègue vincent crasse
pour faux témoignage mais il est plus
surprenant les sénateurs transmettre au
parquet les dossiers de responsables de
l'elysée de hauts fonctionnaires car ils
estiment qu'ils ont retenu une partie de
la vérité face à la commission denquête
il s'agit alors de patrick strzoda
directeur de cabinet des manuels macro
du gnr lionel avait un qui était chef du
j'espère le groupement de sécurité du
président de la république et puis aussi
d'alexis colère le secrétaire général de
l'elysée un très proche des manuels
macron et là encore c'est le premier
ministre qui monte au créneau et qui se
fait un peu leurs avocats écouté
j'observe également qu'un certain nombre
de recommandations concernent des
fonctionnaires qui travaillent auprès du
président de la république et notamment
le secrétaire général de l'elysée de
trouver ces recommandations ou ses
formulations
incompréhensible et souvent injuste car
je peux témoigner de ce que le
secrétaire général de l'elysée notamment
et un grand serviteur de l'état
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne
saisis pas très bien la portée de ces
remarques alors au final le procureur
n'a pas suivi les demandes du sénat n'a
pas en tout cas poursuivi les hauts
fonctionnaires de l'elysée mais cette
séquence a refroidi encore davantage les
relations entre l'exécutif et la haute
assemblée merci alexandre paul cassia je
me tourne vers vous est ce qu'une des
conséquences de la sphère benalla ça n'a
pas été la naissance d'une forme de
contre-pouvoir on se souvient tous deux
de ces images d'audition à l'américaine
avec des sénateurs qui ne s'en laissait
pas conter mais le sénat a tout
simplement fait son travail et en cela
nous a semblé extraordinaire mais ça
n'aurait jamais dû être le cas ce qu'a
dit le premier ministre et ancien
premier ministre edouard philippe est
radicalement faut il a dit que la
séparation des pouvoirs interdisait aux
parlementaires de regarder comment
fonctionne l'elysée c'est tout à fait
faux tous les ans les lois de finances
comporte des passages entiers et des
rapports entier sur la manière dont
l'elysée est organisé et fait une
avancée ce qu'a fait le sénat dans son
rapport qui vient d'être mentionné de 2
2 février 2019 il a porté des
préconisations sur l'organisation du
sénat s'est parfaitement son rôle c'est
heureux que le sénat ait procédé ainsi
parce que l'article 24 de la
constitution dispose que le parlement
contrôle les politiques publiques de
l'exécutif l'organisation de l'elysée
relève de ses politiques publiques il
n'est pas interdit il est même
recommandé que
les parlementaires fassent des
propositions à l'égard de l'exécutif
quitte à ce que celui-ci n'en tiennent
pas compte donc effectivement ici le
problème c'est que l'exécutif a
instrumentalisé la séparation des
pouvoirs à son profit je voudrais juste
donner un exemple au cours des auditions
devant le sénat l'exécutif a brandi la
séparation des pouvoirs pour refuser de
donner le montant de la rémunération de
lexandre benalla ce qui est complètement
absurde
surtout aussi parce que la majorité au
sénat n'était pas la même qu'à
l'assemblée nationale qu' on a pu avoir
cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire il y avait une commission
d'enquêté à l'assemblée nationale comme
elle était tenue par là par la majorité
effectivement labonté mois là beaucoup
moins mordante que que celle du sénat et
le le sénat a aussi lui c'est aussi lui
appuyé sur cette commission d'enquêté
parce que je n'avais pas vraiment
d'opposition emmanuel macron jusque là
pour pour juin vous valoriser un rôle un
rôle d'opposant et revaloriser le rôle
du sénat où tous étaient sans précédent
dans l'histoire la vème république jean
cette
revalorisation cette révélation de ce
qui existait déjà et de la nécessité d
du contre-pouvoir parlementaire oui
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne trouve pas
de manière aussi claire dans les autres
grandes affaires beaucoup d'ailleurs
parce que les prédécesseurs de deux
emmanuel macron ont su beaucoup mieux
que lui et va créer ce que les problèmes
qui se posaient je pense à jacques
chirac et son abracadabrantesque il
aurait fallu que qu'emmanuel macron nous
sortent quelque chose de ce type au lieu
de lieu de se se mettre en scène
lui-même ce monsieur m ce qui est la
plus grande erreur politique que je me
semble de cette affaire c'est lorsqu'il
dit venez me chercher est-ce qu'il se
met sur le même plan que ses adversaires
et parce qu'il le faut callies autour de
lui mais pour revenir oui à cet assaut
contre pouvoir parlementaire c'est c'est
vraiment au fond l'effet très positif de
cette de cette affaire c'est d'avoir
montrer aux français qu'il existait des
commissions d'enquêté qu'elle pouvait
faire un travail efficace mais il faut
pas non plus occulter la dimension
strictement politique et constater que
cette commission à l'été quand même tenu
par les républicains et les socialistes
qui ont trouvé une fantastique
opportunité pour affaiblir
la macro ni mais
sur le long terme c'est intéressant
d'avoir vu comme ça c'est ce contre
pouvoir institutionnel
il faudrait remonter chez pause années
70 lorsque le l'assemblée nationale
avait sanctionné un député proche de
jacques chaban delmas henry reeve henry
pour pour retrouver comme ça le
l'émergence de ceux de son
contre-pouvoir dans une affaire de ce
type mais voilà c'était quand même
malgré tout je répète positif sur le
plan de la re légitimisation de ducey
dame semble t il laetitia nous parlons
là entre experts et vous avez posé une
question en introduction de ce débat
c'est que reste-t-il de la sphère
benalla dans l'opinion publique parce
que quand on regarde l la cote de
popularité emmanuel macron en juillet
effectivement y perd beaucoup et il ya
huit français sur dix qui ne se disent
choqués par cette affaire benalla un an
plus tard donc à malgré la crise des
gilets jaunes malgré cette affaire bénin
emmanuel macron edouard philippe ont
retrouvé exactement le même niveau de
popularité qui est relativement haut
dans l'histoire de la vème république
donc ce qui est important de retenir
bien sûr on des enseignements politiques
institutionnelles sont capitaux
évidemment pour le fonctionnement de la
démocratie mais d'un point de vue de la
population est ce que les français vont
aller voter en 2022 en se rappelant
cette affaire banale à venir est-ce que
ça a marqué un tournant du quinquennat
pour vous la popularité sur le moment
c'est ce qu'on se dit parce qu'eux mêmes
macron c'est un an et demi qu'il est qui
et qui l'installé à l'elysée c'est une
machine à réformer qui est lancé à
pleine vitesse et y'a rien qui lui
résiste je n'y a aucune opposition qui
réussit à se structurer en face de lui
c'est qu'il a il a un champ totalement
libre et il avance vraiment sens sans
aucun aucun obstacle trois ans plus tard
en fait on se rend compte que mêmes
macron il a surtout pris un dos d'âne à
pleine vitesse ça a beaucoup secoué dans
la voiture tout le monde a été un peu
bousculé lui le premier le véhicule
était un peu endommagée mais le les
cartes sorties de route voilà il ya peu
une sortie de route parce que le cap il
l'a maintenue il a essayé de continuer
de reprendre le fil des réformes il
s'est ensuite cogné au gilet jaune il
essayait de reprendre le fils zen début
des ennuis quand même jacques chirac
avait coutume de dire que ça vole en
escadrille sacem ans avec des draps et
après ça n'arrête pas non pas le cas
c'est rappeler la valeur
institutionnelle passe à la trappe oui
c'est le décès le début des ennuis mais
lui continue à avancer d'air à la
rentrée il ya d'autres il ya d'autres
ennuis car il ya la démission de nicolas
hulot il ya le départ de gérard collomb
effectivement ça entraîne tout un tas de
choses la mécanique magique qui l'avait
porté à l'elysée sans rien peu mais le
véhicule continue à avancer un peu moins
vite mais il continue à avancer parce
que l'esa pour vous c'est un tournant
oui le président la république était
présente et je ne sais pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs j'avais jamais compris comme
comme le maître des horloges et on a vu
tout de suite à ce moment là que ce
n'est plus lui qui dictait l'agenda
politique l'agenda public cette affaire
on l'a dit à maintes reprise a eu pour
conséquence d'arrêter net la grande
réforme institutionnelle qui n'auront
n'aura pas lieu pendant tout le
quinquennat il n'y a eu aucune
modification institutionnelle
même mineures au cours de ce quinquennat
proportionnelle qui était une promesse
n'a pas oui alors même que cette réforme
ne nécessite pas de modification de la
constitution ce qui est quand même
parlant des cas et qu'elle est très
demandé par les principaux partenaires
d'affaires de mâcon c'est à dire par le
modem tout à fait le françois bayrou a
menacé à plusieurs reprises de
démissionner de partir de pleurer même
et la réforme n'a pas eu lieu et puis
cette affaire benalla a donné ça vient
d'être appelé par françois-xavier
bourmaud du grain à moudre au gilet
jaune qui chantaient tous les samedis on
va te chercher chez toi et il nous a
invités à aller le chercher à l'elysée
c'est ce qu'ont essayé de faire certains
citoyens mais se sont heurtés à un
déploiement de forces de l'ordre tout à
fait impressionnant moi j'ai vu de mes
yeux vu des des équipements militaires
sur les champs elysées c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très sympa je
n'avais pas eu l'habitude d'avoir pour
reprendre ce que disait laetitia coupat
est ce que vous diriez au fond que ça
l'a affaibli où ça l'a endurci
plutôt endurcis parce que c'est la
première épreuve politique derrière
derrière l' affaire banale acquis le
qu'ils affrontent il yal'affaire bénéat
bon c'est pas une affaire d'état
alexandre bédat là c'est pas le plombier
du matériel mais derrière ça se traduit
par deux motions de censure à
l'assemblée nationale déposez une part
la droite l'autre par l'ailé gauche
réunit donc la motion de censure de la
droite est voté par la gauche en plus
donc il ya vraiment un moment où
derrière la sphère biennale à
l'opposition elle met les maquereaux se
structurent trouve un angle d'attaqué et
comment cela vraiment à prendre sa place
ce quelque chose qu'elle n'avait pas
réussit à faire depuis le début du
quinquennat donc que d'oksa le salon
durcit pas ce que c'est les épreuves
politiques vous endurcissent ça
l'affaiblît sans doute aussi un peu
parce que dans l'opinion il apparaît
plus vraiment comme le nom de ces un
nouveau nom qui fleure bon ancien je
regarde exactement ce que je voulais
dire c'est une perte de virginité par
rapport à ces que c'était un peu penser
à ce qui s'était passé pour les françois
mitterrand et les socialistes en général
la gauche en général lors de la sphère
des délits d'initiés en 1988 ou alain
juppé avait pu dire c'est la gauche la
plus pourrie du monde est bien là vous
avez quelqu'un qui se présentait comme
l'homme du nouveau monde qui abandonnait
et qu'ils voulaient une république
exemplaire et qui montre aux français et
à son opposé surtout à l'opposition
bakil et voilà il qu'il est comme les
autres il a dissimulé quelque chose qui
est une déviance qui est une mauvaise
organisation
et puis il ya une deuxième imputation
alors cette route toujours très
difficile après de mesurer l'impact de
ce type de comment dire de d'affaires ou
de scandales en terme d'image mais
n'oublions pas que l'image c'est ça va
être décisif aussi au moment d'une
campagne présidentielle mais le deuxième
élément c'est donc d'une part
l'amateurisme et l'amateurisme regardez
cette thématique elle est quand même
beaucoup revenu au moment de la réforme
des retraites lorsque le conseil d'état
a sanctionné elle est revenue au moment
de la gestion de de l'aco vide c'est une
thématique qui revient en permanence en
tout cas du côté de ses opposants donc
ces images-là
amateurisme ancien monde en tout cas
pratiques de dopage cité et c'est tout
ça ce sont des choses qui peu à peu
s'infiltre dans les mentalités
collectives et on ne sait pas quelle
peut être à terme l'impact de ces de ces
thèmes est à point de vue politique sa
marque la fin des réformes
non non non parce que l'obsession
l'obsession des mêmes macron dès la
rentrée et malgré les contre coups et
les départs de hulot et les colons son
obsession c'est de reprendre le fil des
réformes et de continuer il essaye mais
alors évidemment on en parlait la forme
constitutionnel ça peut plus marcher
il essaie quand même d'y revenir
régulièrement pendant tout le reste du
quinquennat donc ça ne marque pas la fin
des réformes même là les gilet jaune met
les réformes entre parenthèses
mais paille à la fin des le gilet jaune
il essaie de relancer la machine après à
la fin déjà très apprécié à la fois des
problèmes
et à des radiations sont plus des textes
régalien on va dire puisque les voilà si
tu as été global la loi sur le
séparatisme et des grandes réformes
économiques et sociales il y en a eu
moins ça sans doute ralenti la machine
ça a commencé à ralentir la machine et
puis après ils ces deux murs des deux
crises gilet jaune puis sanitaire qui
laurent qu'il aura plus en plus et je
voudrais qu'on écoute ensemble une
déclaration du président de la
république nous sommes le 25 avril 2019
d'une conférence de presse à l'elysée
emmanuel macron évoque la sphère benalla
sur alexandre benalla
c'est trop facile de regretter
est-ce que je pense
qu'au moment où j'étais élu
connaissons ce jeune garçon qui avait
vraiment du talent qui s'était engagé
dans ma campagne
qui avait son histoire est ce que je
regrette de l'avoir embauché à l'elysée
non
parce que je pense que c'était
extrêmement cohérent avec les valeurs
que je porte avec ce que je veux que
nous fassions est ce que l'elysée a tiré
les leçons de cette affaire en tout cas
lors de cette conférence de presse
en fait il est tellement
jupitérien pour ne pas dire hautain et
méprisant qu'il ne reconnaîtra jamais
qui s'est pris les pieds dans le tapis
et ça c'est à l'erreur fondamentale des
manuels macron sur tous les dossiers
parce qu'on a vu quand edouard philippe
a commencé à faire preuve d'humilité
profil bas ça a fonctionné c'est à dire
qu'on accepte certaines erreurs quand
elles sont reconnues or là jusqu'au bout
emmanuel macron a concédé une erreur on
n'a pas pris la juste mesure on n'a pas
su apprécier s'est passé à l'erreur or à
mon avis il s'enferme dans son
personnage le personnage qu'il a
construit là il voulait être acteur
c'est un grand numéro d'acteur ce
silence où on est pendus à ses lèvres
finalement c'est parfois ça peut être
pris plus tôt comme d'une façon un peu
pathétique il me semble qu efficace ça
fait d'ailleurs penser à une autre
phrase des meilleurs mc ronde je sais
plus trop bas de quelque est la réforme
il il avait prononcé mais quand il dit
ce n'est pas un échec ça n'a pas marché
ça c'est un peu la même chose ça renvoie
cette idée de ne pas reconnaître
effectivement qu'à un moment ça a coincé
est ce que l'elysée a tiré les leçons de
cette affaire
sur le sur l'encadrement
vraisemblablement oui là pour le coup et
même macron
ap a fait le ménage dans son entourage
mais en tout cas beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus vigilant sur ses collaborateurs
y avait ça paraît quand même fou que les
services n'est pas screen également dit
enfin n'est pas enquêté il faut ce
collaborateur du président il faut se
remettre dans l'état d'esprit de cette
équipe qui arrive à l'elysée après avoir
après avoir commandé au casse du siècle
et à 10 soit pour assurer le bon
fonctionnement des gimmicks
elysées qui il manque à l'elysée je
pense que ça a été corrigé de paix mais
qui manque une sorte de service de dow
drh en fait qu'ils soient capables un
petit peu de réguler tout ça à l'elysée
ça n'existait pas avant la sphère
benallou en tout cas de manière très
très informés alors par et ça n'existe
toujours pas c'est en projet et je me
souviens benalla lui-même participé à
des réunions doré aucun fashion souviens
je les lui
participé à des réunions de
réorganisation des services de sécurité
de coordination etc mais on sent qu'il
ya un flou terrible et ça c'est toute
une histoire parce que ça a toujours
fonctionné comme ça l'elysée c'est une
machine où il ya énormément de zones
d'ombré et énormément de deux
fonctionnaires qui ne sont pas
véritablement enregistré deux
conseillers dont on ne sait pas s'ils
sont vraiment conseillé admis conseiller
ou conseillers du soir enfin c'est quand
même je vous avais toujours
correspondent pas toujours aux mêmes
macron il aime s'entourer de personnes
qui ont des regards décalés et qui vont
pas lui apporter ce que vous lui
apportez des énarques ou les les
spécialistes alexandre bédat il fait
quelque chose à un moment il débarque
dans le bureau des mails macro élus et
démontre qu'on peut entrer dans son
bureau par la rue en face de l'elysée en
deux minutes un commando armé ou les
amarres mais peuvent débarquer dans son
bureau en deux minutes et suite à ça
c'est là qui réorganise entièrement la
sécurité autour du autour du palais qui
font monter les plots qui met les
grilles et ce regard là qu'apportait
alexandre benalla c'est ça qu'on
recherchait et même un coin c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont toujours aussi de ceux
qui sont au bas de ce type de profil
paul cassia puisqu'on en est à tirer les
leçons est ce que d'un point de vue
institutionnel aujourd'hui une autre
affaire benalla serait possible avec un
autre parce que moi d'un regard ailleurs
j'ai pas l'impression que grand chose et
échanger on nous avait promis une
réorganisation de l'elysée elle a
peut-être eu lieu en tout cas sa
publicité n'a pas été fait elle a été
promise à plusieurs reprises elle avait
été annoncé d'ailleurs avant la sphère
benalla je crois à savoir qu'une société
de conseil privé a été mandaté pour
proposer une réorganisation des services
de l'elysée et je n'ai pas moi comme
citoyen comme juriste étaient avisés de
ce qui avait pu se dérouler ce qui a été
choquant aussi pour moi c'est que ont
parlé d'amateurisme c'est que alexandre
banana qui était un collaborateur
contractuelle de l'elysée donc il avait
été recruté ça a été dit par le
président la république par le fait du
prince j'ai décidé que alexandre reynal
à recruter et puis je lui ai confié
telle ou telle mission ce qui le rendait
en était incontrôlable par quelques
services que ce soit d'où la dérive de
la place de la contrescarpe et du jardin
et plan ce qui n'a ce qui a été oublié
c'est que et bien les chargés de mission
n'était contrôlé par personne alors
qu'ils auraient pu l'être l'elysée
n'avait pas transmis les déclarations de
patrimoine et les déclarations
d'intérêts des différents collaborateurs
recrutés par élise et à la haute
autorité de la transparence pour la vie
publique ce qui aurait dû être fait en
application d'une loi de 2013 voilà une
autre manifestation de la matrice de
l'elysée ça c'est une leçon qui va être
tiré mais je crois que plus personne à
l'elysée n'oubliera cette nécessité mais
pour le reste je ne sais pas je pense
qu'une autre affaire benalla et il n'est
pas exclu jean garrigues la sphère
benalla ça sera une ligne ou un chapitre
où apparaîtront dès lundi soir dans mon
lit c'est un chapitre
mais c'est un chapitre parce qu'on l'a
dit alors d'abord ça a été une étape
marquante majeur un tournant dans
l'histoire du du quinquennat parce
qu'elle a révélé je le répète cette une
tendance longue de l'elysée d'abord à
cette opacité organisationnel puis à ce
réflexe d'opacité faso face aux affaires
ça a révélé une part aussi d'amateurisme
au plus haut sommet de l'état ce a
révélé j insiste quand même la toute
puissance aussi de l'institution
présidentielle je répète dont se
réclamait alexandre viala et d'autres
d'ailleurs dans la dans la sphère ma
chronique ou d'avant parce que ça ça
vraiment existé à tous et à toutes les
époques se toutes les présidences et ça
pose je répète ça pose véritablement le
problème de de la place de la présidence
de ce qu'on considère que doivent être
les non seulement les pouvoirs je dirais
institutionnels mais les pouvoirs réels
d'un président de la république et la
manière dont nous pouvons le contrôle et
dont les citoyens peuvent peuvent le
contrôler donc ça citoyens et les médias
d'ailleurs donc ça s'arrose de
transparence c'est un problème de
transparence mais mélangeur au troll
couac est majeur parce qu'il s'est posé
à toutes les époques pour tous les
présidents
parler de françois mitterrand les abus
de pouvoir de françois mitterrand le
rainbow warrior les irlandais de
vincennes toutes ces choses ou
directement le président de la
république ou moins directement
diligente est d'aider des opérations ou
par des des hommes à lui de son
entourage et ça s'est trouvé sous
sarkozy sous françois hollande aussi on
l'a beaucoup moins sûr mais toutes ces
systèmes là si vous voulez y pose la
question de quels sont les pouvoirs d'un
président de la république point barre
françois-xavier bourmaud
là ma chronique on dit en tout cas
l'exécutif surveille ce qui se dit au
procès ils ont peur ils sont donc dans
quel état d'esprit il jette un coup
d'oeil mission sur autre chose la sphère
benalla pour eux c'est vraiment ça
appartient au passé c'est terminé
maintenant il ya les élections
présidentielles qui arrivent et cette
affaire a pas imprégnés l'opinion en
tout cas sur le le
la grande affaire du quinquennat la
grande affaire de fond qui est la
structuration d'un nouveau clivage
politique
entre les progressistes et conservateurs
la ferme hélas n'a strictement aucun
impact est la même je me sens bien mais
il redoute pas d'aider des révélations
des médias tu leur dis voilà il ya il
reste un point d'interrogation c'est le
sait le coffre fort et est devenu ce
tonnage que les médias apprécié objet
d'une enquête journalistique ou
peut-être d'un roman ou en tout cas d'un
livre merci c'est la fin de ce débat sur
les conséquences politiques de la sphère
benalla je rappelle vos livres
françois-xavier bourmaud coauteur avec
charles sapin de macron l'open de tendre
des fossoyeurs aux éditions de
l'archipel jean garrigues hauteur de les
scandales de la république de panama à
la sphère benalla aux éditions du
nouveau monde merci à tous merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'est la fin de
cette émission vous retrouverez thomas
hugues dès lundi à 18 heures pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public demain
matin n'oubliez pas bonjour chez vous au
rayonnement de signer reçoit alexis
corbière député insoumis de
seine-saint-denis à 8 heures salut à
tous merci